idling away the time in a former army
barracks in folkestone in kent these men
are waiting for their asylum claims to
be processed
this is napier a vast and controversial
site which campaigners insist isn't
suitable for those fleeing conflict it
was due to close now the government says
with improvements it will stay open
until 2025.
this former army barracks is supposed to
be used to house single healthy male
asylum seekers but such is the urgent
need for accommodation there are
concerns it's being used as a test site
for large scale reception centers
accommodation concerns have been starkly
highlighted in a letter to mps looking
into immigration facilities by the
immigration minister kevin foster
he writes hotel availability is impacted
by the work currently underway to bring
afghan families to safety the provision
of managed quarantine service
accommodation and the revival of our
domestic tourism industry as lockdown
restrictions have been removed across
the uk
the accommodation at napier was set up
in response to the pandemic these
pressures remain and are being
exacerbated by the unprecedented rise in
dangerous and illegal small boat
crossings
sky news was recently given footage
filmed by asylum seekers inside napier
showing little privacy outside the camp
we met jamsheed and hoijat from iran who
arrived in the uk in june after crossing
the channel by a small boat they
described the facility as like a jail
for the
sleeping
is not very good because it's a lot of
people are making way in the night and
no one have a space
but with a surge in boat arrivals across
the channel it's emerged the uk and
ghana are talking about ways ghana can
help alleviate the uk's immigration
problems the ghana foreign ministry has
deleted a tweet about a virtual meeting
which discussed issues of mutual
interest between ghana and the uk
particularly in areas of security and
migration notably in matters relating to
third country asylum partnerships as the
uk makes plans to reform its asylum
system the plan that the uk has at the
moment is to send asylum seekers to
another country where that country would
take responsibility for taking decisions
on their claims it's certainly
conceivable that the uk government has
been talking to the ghanaian government
about this asylum offshoring plan that
the government here in the uk says it
wants to do that
the foreign office says a virtual
meeting took place with ghana on a range
of policy issues the uk is considering
how to solve its migration influx with
solutions at home and abroad lisa
holland sky news foxton